our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us every
year nearly 2 million more Americans are
diagnosed with cancer one innovative
organization is letting cancer survivors
and their supporters lace up their
gloves to give cancer a knockout blow
chip Reid is at a boxing gym near the
nation's capital where some of the
fighters trained shipped good morning
well good morning you might think the
last thing a cancer survivor would want
to do is climb into a boxing ring and
put their body through another pummeling
but we found some people who have done
exactly that they're doing it to raise
money for haymakers for hope at age 31
any Dragovich got blindsided by breast
cancer but now healthy she picked this
fight did you ever in your wildest
dreams imagine yourself in a boxing ring
never know any is here with the help of
haymakers for Hope a nonprofit that
pairs people who are literally fighting
for a cure let's just say you don't want
to fight a cancer survivor the group's
founders met at the gym so you are a
champion amateur boxer am i beyond your
range where I'm sitting right now I can
get to you pretty quick julienne Kelly
is also a cancer survivor after
treatment I kind of fell into a little
bit of a depression and I just said to
myself you're here other people don't
get to experience what you're
experiencing throw that out and do
something good and I started boxing and
I just absolutely fell in love with the
sport it was medicine for me just as
much as chemo and radiation was it was
something that I needed now in its ninth
year haymakers for hope has raised more
than 13 million dollars at 26 events
including Belles of the brawl featuring
female fighters rumble in the Rockies
and this one in Washington thank you
we're Pranava fora a lymphoma survivor
also stepped into the ring is there
anybody you know who you think might be
looking forward to you getting punched
in the face plenty of people haymakers
for hope provides a trainer and a gym
and they're not holding any punches
this is the real thing this is the real
thing yeah I expect that my opponents
gonna come out ready to knock me out so
seriously not any spent four months in
grueling training learning how to defend
against and land haymakers of her own
for now five days a week even with his
own business two young kids and a wife
who wasn't always on board I didn't tell
my wife until after the fact and so
everyday she's like if you want to
continue doing anything like this we're
gonna have a discussion about it but on
fight night she was in his corner
[Music]
inez cheering section
included her mother and sister also a
cancer survivors
tough enough to beat more than breast
cancer and the winner winning with the
confidence that comes when you've
already won the fight of your life you
don't have to be a cancer survivor to do
this in fact anybody who wants to fight
cancer can volunteer in fact haymakers
for hope is having their biggest event
ever next month in New York City and
Tony you might want to check and see if
it's too late to sign up those face
cards but they always say your attitude
is so important when you're going
through something like that and I would
think you'd have a really great attitude
if you could get in the ring and just
hit somebody yeah there's a hell of a
punch I have warriors there a beer there
then